yes
so some of you probably already know uh
i
finally got a software engineering job
now
i'm super grateful and super relieved
that i don't have to
interview anymore i mean interviewing is
super stressful and it's not that fun
like i i really hate interviewing well i
mean actually
i i think i hate before interviewing
because that's when you get the most
stressed but then when you're
interviewing and if you're
actually doing really well it actually
feels kind of good it feels kind of good
but i'm glad i don't need to leak code
anymore i mean
i did it so much that it kind of became
a habit every day i just go home
lead code a little bit and a part of me
kind of
a part of me kind of wants to just
continually coding every day just to
keep my skills fresh
my interviewing skills fresh you know
you never know if you want to switch
jobs or not
so the reason why i didn't say anything
for the longest time
is because i didn't want to jinx it i
wanted everything to be
confirmed and finalized before telling
you
but uh yeah i've been working for a few
weeks now and um
yeah it seems okay i i think i got the
job for sure now so
i can tell you guys now so due to
privacy concerns
i'm i'm not gonna share which company it
is
um maybe once i quit i can share which
company it is
but um you know you know i don't plan on
quitting anytime
soon but i can tell you that the company
is part of fang
i'm incredibly happy that i got this job
offer
uh i'm actually really grateful
and um yeah like it's always kind of
been my dream job back then and
yeah so for full transparency sake uh i
have a total compensation of 278
000 for the first year and then in the
later years it's less than that because
i had a sign-on bonus
so i want to tell you exactly how i
transitioned from data scientist
to software engineer from the day that i
wanted to switch
to software engineering so i was still
at facebook when i decided to transition
into
software engineering i talked to my
friends one of them was a data engineer
who switched into software engineering
to get some info
i asked them about different companies
what the culture was like
what kind of questions they asked during
interviews what was the pay
how long does it take for the recruiters
to respond back what tech stack they use
etc etc so i was just gathering
information
so i kind of already had a list of
companies that i wanted to apply to
during the same week i refreshed my
python skills
i mean i haven't coded in like forever i
think the last time i coded was during
my internship at linkedin
which was winter 2015. i used python 2
before
but i decided to relearn or slash learn
python 3 just because it's newer
and it's almost the same thing except
for a few little syntax differences
so i had to relearn how python does
their list comprehensions array
strings lambdas their syntax for
dictionaries
their string stuff and also like common
libraries that we would usually use in a
coding interview
so that took me about two days yeah then
i started lead coding
and i actually just focused on the easy
questions
and the reason why is because i i
couldn't even do them
so i wouldn't even try to do the medium
questions until i could flash
the easy questions by the way no one
uses the term flash
i use the term flash because in
bouldering
when you flash a climb it means you did
it in one shot
so for interviews i mean for interview
questions
i say you flash the question if you just
run it once and you get it
on your first try without looking at the
answers so i did about
30 to 40 easy questions before i can
actually
flash these easy questions and that took
about two to three weeks
not bad i did like one to two questions
a day i was
slowly practicing i mean i still had a
full-time job
so i didn't have that that much time i
was also kind of sad at that time
so i exercised a lot to try to cope
with that and that also took away from
my coding time
failing this legal question really
wasn't great for my self-esteem
especially at the beginning when i was
failing all these questions
it it felt pretty bad i mean like my
self-esteem was pretty low
and then in addition you have to grind
these questions
and every question that you miss you
just feel like uh you're a failure
so it was kind of hard in the beginning
but in the end it was worth it
after that i started doing medium
questions now to this day i don't think
i can
flash medium questions i mean they're
pretty hard
some medium questions are a lot easier
than others it really depends because it
kind of depends on your strengths and
your weaknesses
some of them i could flash but some of
them i cannot i can't even solve them
so it's kind of hard to say but i still
did a lot of them
and then the more you do the easier they
become in the meantime
i decided to actually start applying to
jobs because i told myself that i needed
to put deadlines
because without deadlines i'm just going
to slack and i'm not going to practice
seriously
so i polished my resume because my
resume was kind of built in a more
data science pme role so a lot of the
bullet points i had to change to make it
more
software related for example for my data
science job
i would focus more on the data
engineering aspect of the job
and then for my pm experience i would
talk about how i prototyped
these products which requires coding so
that i could present it to clients and
stuff like that
getting interviews was actually really
easy for me because i've built a
foundation
ever since i started doing internships
so over the course of all those
internships i've built
connections friends you know and a whole
network
of recruiters slash friends so for
literally
any tech company i have at least a
friend who works there
or a recruiter that i can contact
because i've already interviewed there
for internships the reason why i can
contact these recruiters is because back
then
when i was interviewing for internships
i actually got offers from them
and because they remember me they'll
answer my email and they'll give me at
least a phone
interview so yeah waterloo is the [ __ ]
because you get a whole network of tech
professionals
you'll get a referral for any company
you want to apply for
as long as you made friends back in
college and i don't want to brag but
i had a handful of friends in college so
i wanted to study
full-time and go ham on the coding
because i knew that getting the
interviews
was not my problem my problem was
actually passing the interview
so i decided to quit my job and lead
code full time
but that didn't happen i ended up doing
youtube a lot and i pretty much studied
the same amount as before okay maybe not
the same amount but
just a little bit more so i studied
about like two to four hours a day
which means like three to five questions
i usually do about three to five
questions per day
and then maybe on the weekends slightly
more maybe five hours
i was getting more and more familiar
with the questions i was recognizing the
patterns i was learning the tricks right
and it's not even about intelligence or
or being smart or anything it's
literally just practice
because the questions end up looking the
same they only change the context or the
wording
or the storyline behind it but it's
essentially the same thing
so four weeks later i had my first phone
interview
and i passed almost all of them
because it's they're not super super
hard it's only like a first smoke screen
and most of the time you might get a
question that you've seen already on
leak code so that makes a lot easier
it's technically kind of cheating but
whatever
after the phone interviews i also asked
to push the on-site interviews as far as
possible because i just wasn't confident
in myself yet so i wanted more time to
study
so i did like 150 to 200 questions by
then
but i didn't feel like i was getting
that much better
so i bought the book elements of program
oh yeah i think i have it
so i bought the book elements of
programming interviews in python
because i wanted to practice coding
using a pen and paper
unlike using a computer and a platform
because
that is a lot more similar to when
you're asked the question using a
whiteboard during interviews
i think it's similar to hard mode when
you use pen and paper
to write your code because you have to
be a lot more thoughtful because you
can't erase
then during real interviews i actually
have a white board and i could use the
eraser
it's gonna feel a lot easier so two or
three days
before the on-site interview i would
stop doing youtube
and i would study all day for three days
i would order delivery so that i don't
waste time so i would study around 10 to
12 hours
per day before the interview i would do
a combination of leak code and paper
coding using elements of programming
interview
i would also go to glassdoor to look at
the interview question for that specific
company
and do them i also ask around my friends
to see what kind of questions they got
during their interview usually the
questions won't be the same but at least
you get a sense
of what the companies like to ask for
example facebook
they don't ask dynamic programming
questions but google they love to ask
dynamic programming questions if i
learned that the company asked system
design
questions then i would go read grokking
the system design interview
and i would just try to you know take
everything in and hope that i remember
so at that point i've done around 230
questions on the code
and i don't know how many i've done on
pen and paper i actually over studied
because there were so many things
that i practiced for that i didn't use
like for example union find
for disjoint sets i didn't use that
sorry i can't think of any examples um
i've already forgotten everything i've
learned
because i already got an offer so i
don't get so yeah i passed a few of
those interviews and i failed some of
them
and then using the offers i kind of
negotiated so that my tc would go
up and then until no one can increase
anymore i just accepted the offer
saying it now it doesn't sound like much
it's just study and that's it
but while i was studying holy [ __ ] i
felt like [ __ ]
but i was lucky that i had roommates
and friends to support me when i most
need them to tell me
that i'm being too hard on myself to
calm me down
i kind of just wanted to say again that
thank you for understanding when i was
away from youtube for so long
and thank you for everyone who sent all
these
positive messages to me encouraging me
to find a new job in software
engineering
i really really appreciate that thank
you so much
i love you
[Music]
all right it's a new chapter in my life
i think it's a pretty good start
[Music]
more